[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم
يزور خرسون لتفقد اثار تفجير سردك
والفيضانات الناجمه عنه ويصف الامر
بالكارثه في حين تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه
انما حدث قد يؤدي لخساره ملايين الاطنان
من الحبوب وموسكو تتهم القوات الاوكرانيه
باستهداف رجال الانقاذ الروس في منطقه
الفيضانات وبقصف محطه كهرباء
كخفقه على واقع توتر مستمر في شرق اسيا
اليابان تقول ان السفينتين صينيتين دخلت
مياهها الاقليميه وتؤكد انها قدمت احتجاجا
للصين من جانبها حتى الصين كلا من
الولايات المتحده واليابان على الالتزام
بمبدا صين واحده والامتناع عن اثاره
التوترات في مضيق تايوان وزير الداخليه
الفرنسي يعلنوا اصابه بضعه اشخاص بينهم
اطفال في هجوم بسكين في مدينه انسي جنوب
شرقي البلاد ويؤكد اعتقال المهاجم في حين
قالت مصادر ان منفذ الهجوم حاصل على صفه
لاجئ والادعاء العام يقول ان منفذ اعتداء
مدينه انسي لم يتحرك بدافع ارهابي النجم
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي يعلن عزمه
الانضمام الى نادي انتر ميامي الامريكي في
صفقه انتقال حر بعدما كثرت الاخبار عن
عودته الى ناديه السابق برشلونه او الذهاب
الى السعوديه ويقول ان انتقاله الى امريكا
يهدف الى تجربه نمط جديد في كره القدم
بهدوء اكبر الى اللقاء